c'est un autre débat qui est ouvert dans
l'opinion les milieux politiques des
milieux gouvernementaux on l'appelle de
parfois de façon parfois un peu
impersonnel
le problème de l'emploi nous n'avons pas
ce soir l'ambition d'ouvrir ce dossier
mais simplement de vous raconter
quelques histoires c'est le hasard qui
nous les a indiqué mais chacune à leur
façon elle a tout à comprendre
[Musique]
lundi 2 février à 9h30 du matin rue
réaumur
[Musique]
oh
monsieur andré giraud vous êtes le
directeur de la plus importante agence
de petites annonces en france il y a
actuellement un problème de l'emploi est
ce que ce problème se reflète sur les
petites annonces oui il se reflète d'une
façon importante parce que dans france
soir notamment le marché du travail
représentent 60% des lignages c'est vous
dire l'importance le souci que nous
attachons aux problèmes de l'emploi il y
a en ce moment incontestablement du
chômage tout le monde le reconnaît et de
ma fenêtre
si vous avez pu le voir ce matin je
mesure le nombre de demandeurs d'emploi
qui chaque jour attend la sortie de la
première édition de france soir pour se
précipiter sur les emplois sur certains
emplois offerts
monsieur vous venez d'acheter le journal
vous vous êtes précipité je crois tout
de suite sur la colonne qui vous
intéressait une telle recette hôtellerie
la colonne 37
avez vous trouvé quelque chose pour lui
je pense que si vous aviez trouvé
vous ne seriez pas large au déjà partie
oui vous seriez déjà parti pour être
premier exactement combien y at il des
annonces dans cette colonne hôtellerie
c'est à dire journellement ou vendus
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
2 3 4 5 6 7
mais il y en a 10 et aucune ne vous
convient
on ne demande pas de recette jolie jeune
femme de chambre sam de chambre des
serveuses ou décevoir young avenger aux
joueurs qu'ils ont que s'il remettait
donc aucun réceptionniste d'hôtel les
demander allez vous revenir demain oui
et les autres jours c'est nécessaire
depuis deux semaines tous les matins
vous êtes ici à partir de quelle heure
plus tard à 8 heures et le journal saura
à 9h30 nous est en chômage depuis quand
que ça ça fait depuis mardi ça va faire
huit jours dix bougies m'en servir en 15
jours et dans le fromage était l'échangé
de brut depuis le 22 mai et depuis le 22
mai j'ai travaillé juste le je suis
rentré en novembre je suis sa ville
en décembre il avait juste à moi depuis
le
depuis le 22 mai vous avez une formation
professionnelle si j'ai une formation
profession de quelle sorte c'est twitter
oui lutte mais le bilan n'est pas
exercée parce que j'ai pas trouvé
directement du corps à son ambition de
formation professionnelle alors je suis
comme j'étais déjà prêtes en bâtiment
alors j'ai cherché cette brique dans une
journée comme bien d'un lisez-vous de
petites annonces dans le textile
oui une ou deux une ou deux faces et du
ce et vous y rendez vous rendez à la
grèce tout limiterez et ce n'est jamais
très intéressant où le sol est celle
adressée votre adresse où on a quelqu'un
essayait depuis ou deux jours laisser
votre adresse on vous envoie c'est à
dire où la passe était prise au moment
où j'écris
cadres 30 en direction commerciale vente
édition 8 ans d'expérience dans la
profession vendent diffusion
organisation services commerciaux
référence premier ordre
libre de suite vous avez passé une
annonce il ya combien de temps il y
avait joué les bijoux vous avez reçu
combien de réponses
trois réponses dont deux valables et que
vous êtes rendu à ces adresses
non je vous écris j'ai envoyé mon
curriculum vitae et maquis photo oui est
ce que vous pensiez avoir tellement de
difficultés ayant huit ans d'expérience
et en ce que l'on appelle un jeune cadre
à retrouver un travail
au départ non maintenant je me rends
compte et vous seriez-vous prêt à
accepter n'importe quoi n'importe quoi
postes à responsabilités tout de même
j'ai un excellent moral actuellement
c'est la famille qu'il faut soutenir
bien souvent mais si cela devait
continuer plusieurs mois encore je sais
je sens que moral lequel aurait pas de
scoop hollandais je viens dans l'antre
disant que j'avais en france et j'ai
fait le travail comme chef de chantier
ou même celle des tic dans le bâtiment
et depuis combien de temps et devant
chômage maintenant leurs semelles de
swing chômage 9 semaines
est-ce que vous pensez que ce temps
assez long est due à la crise qui lie
actuellement dans le bâtiment au risque
revient comme la dernière année comme
chef de chantier tous les jours présenté
au mali au gaz portant sur des chantiers
de mon travail
on n'avait pas et maintenant c'est vous
qui
n'en avaient pas même comme chef de
chantier est-ce que vous déplacer
souvent nos adresses indiquées par les
petites annonces avaient tous les jours
parce que tous les jours je me déplace
je vais chercher le droit de faire tout
le côté de la jeunesse en général si les
prétentions champions le dis je suis
trop vieux con j'ai 48 ans et puis je
préfère du jeune génération qui peut
rester plus longtemps dans la maison et
quand je me présente moi même seront
changés pour le travail qui se fait
souvent le matin en partant prendre tous
les chantiers qui se trouve sur la route
on deviendra le fait déjà un signe avec
les mains ou en rupture et peut dire la
gare ne rien et des autres oiseaux si on
leur demande d'asile souvent ainsi elles
sont plutôt de construire et où
l'espagnol ça veut dire la payer parrot
comme ça se font à la fin tout le monde
plus sûr chemin je puis l'un d'eux
laurent donc douze semaines
j'ai encore été ce matin pour trouver
une place qui demandait compagnon pas il
y avait 100 personnes au moins pour deux
places
avant j'étais montant l'antenne avant de
partir l'armée rentrant du service
militaire j'ai suivi un cours de
formation professionnelle pour adultes
je suis sorti avec un crp de peintre en
bâtiment compagnon lire et j'ai toujours
même avec cette qualification il est
toujours rien trouvé parce que
maintenant les patrons demandent plutôt
des des étrangers que les français même
avec des diplômes
alors tous les jours maintenant j'ai un
rôle au mur un franc soir pour trouver
une place devenue pensionnaire va
tellement bien parce que ça paye pas
tellement monsieur quel est votre métier
exactement je suis organiste qu'un
descendant liste de variétés
j'accompagne eu pas mal de lettres
chaque compagnie aussi pas mal de
vedettes et je le jure maintenant de le
changer de probation carrément j'ai eu
un grave accident de voiture et je ne
veux prendre le risque de faire beaucoup
de route pour faire de tournée et c'est
pourquoi je veux changer de métier et
d'autre part j'ai 31 ans maintenant et
je sens que dans cinq ans ou peut-être
mi-temps on voudra plus de moi lorsque
mais il faut peut-être jeunes
je fais trois mois vous cherchez du
travail vous avez fait combien de
déplacement pour répondre les anneaux
fais-moi une quarantaine selon plus
chaque fois c'était hausse des prix ou
alors le prix d'un homme est arrêté par
rapport aux dépenses qu'on a à faire
dans la semaine
est-ce que vous avez l'impression que
c'est plus difficile pour une femme oui
c'est d'ailleurs très difficile parce
que on demande beaucoup plus de diplômes
indiqué un homme rentre beaucoup plus
facilement dans une maison sans diplôme
que tel sam quoi puis le prix vraiment
inférieur à alors est ce que vous
pensiez en venant à paris que la vie
serait aussi difficile à lyon après le
climat n'est pas allé plus loin
c'est comme ça quand même station total
ce nom
les autres aston
il était il n'offre pas aux états unis
et
vous savez la bid
en dehors du japon ils ne parlent s'est
passé très vite du travail
c'est avec beaucoup de réticence que
nous avait reçus nous avions lu votre
petite annonce dans journal vous ne
tenez pas tellement ce que l'on vous
voit de face à ce que l'on vous
dévisagent pourtant vous sortez d'une
grande école et il semble que pour vous
unir à tellement de problèmes pour
trouver un emploi
il y avait porté le monde problème au
départ c'est à dire quand j'ai commencé
tous comment elle va annoncer c'était
que après quelques années d'études
d'ailleurs et les débouchés surtout
qu'on en ce moment au moins trois bases
de scientifiques en fait y'a qu'à voir
tous les discours que les gens et si je
veux pas de face c'est qu'en fait je le
quitte et franchement je tiens d'abord
je trouve pas que mon cas est tellement
exemplaire puisque tient pas être
reconnu puis surtout je tiens par
tellement a protesté je voudrais encore
découvrir j'espère quelque chose c'est
c'est presque un lieu commun tout le
monde dit que l'avenir est aux
scientifiques
je sais pas c'est peut-être un préjugé
mais où pour moi la petite annonce et
les gens qui ne sont pas qualifiés c'est
les gens qui ont quand on a un diplôme
et on a fait quelques années d'études je
croyais que ne serait ce que par
l'amicale des anciens élèves que
j'arriverai à quelque chose et c'est
assez un peu comme l'hôpital la petite
annonce c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que je
veux pas être pris de face à face
laissait alors au départ ça me
paraissait normal vous allez voir les
gens ils vous donnent rendez-vous vous
revenez vous attendez on a même
l'impression qu'on a le choix
et puis on prend un certain plaisir à
traîner au silence la pression d'avoir
des places de réserve
surtout qu'on avait quand même quelques
exemples autour de soi de gens qui ont
réussi et puis petit à petit la
situation c'est s'est figé embourbé les
alliés et vous avez quel âge l'écouté
j'ai l'âge de ce qu ont terminé leurs
études quoi j'ai comme 7 27 ans et pour
vous c'est une surprise
à 27 ans de vous découvrir sans travail
c'est plus qu'une surprise parce que je
connais un tas de gens qui ont fait des
toutes petites écoles techniques vous
savez on vous donne une petite formation
électronique vous dépanner les
télévisions n'importe quoi ouais avec un
an et demi de travail et d'étude vous
avez tout de suite un boulot et surtout
ça crée des difficultés au point de vue
de là haut mais de la vie quotidienne
même si je pouvais aller au chômage je
n'irai pas au chômage aurait aussi
l'impression l'adel à la soupe populaire
n'y a pas de raison de faire des études
pendant les années et se retrouver dans
cette situation
[Applaudissements]
malheureusement ce n'est pas la première
fois que le chômage ça fait pour la
troisième fois
c'était une voix en 1934 j'étais neuf
mois et c'est au moment de la grande
période d'avant crise de dépression de
1930 4g était de nouveau en 1960 nouveau
pour neuf mois et par la suite j'ai
trouvé du travail
mais j'étais de nouveau licencié en mai
en 1964 et depuis soixante-quatre suis
sans travail du fait que je fais une
spécialité gorgi et égorgée ça consiste
enlever les parties excédentaire
lorsqu'on a affiché la semelle est alors
du fait que maintenant la fabrication
est complètement changé quand on utilise
pour l'incident du cuir comme sommes
l'âge mais la matière plastique
le métier de gorgier a complètement
disparu et de ce fait ils mettent
impossible de trouver un emploi d'autant
plus que vu mon âge et bientôt 61 ans ce
n'est pas possible que je m'adresse à un
centre de formation professionnelle a
accéléré
d'autre part j'ai du fait de nos métiers
que j'étais pendant 40 ans dans la
chaussure qui j'ai toujours travaillé
ainsi j'ai une déviation de la colonne
vertébrale et qui m'empêche de rester
très longtemps debout qu'au bout d'une
heure on est prêt je suis debout
je suis fatigué il faut absolument que
je m'assoie c'était monteux dans les
jouets en peluche
j'ai abordé mon métier au bout de trois
ans j'ai eu un accident j'ai le la
fracture du rocher est là quand j'ai été
soigné et guéri à l'hôpital
saint-antoine
j'ai demandé au chef parce qu'on faisait
le montage et la manutention par le
montage qu'est ce que c'est que le
montage vous avez pas de travail sur la
table
bon ça c'est rien mais en plus il faut
faire la manutention pour aller chercher
des
des grosses caisses qui allait jouer
enfin tout pour les monter tout ça
alors voilà les pattes est maintenant je
ne peux plus beaucoup de tournées j'ai
demandé au shérif mais ce n'était pas
possible qu'il voulait faire il pouvait
pas faire pour une pourtant de voiliers
avec moi je trouve que c'est normal
c'est pour ça j'ai quitté l nos moyens
pour rives se décompose un de deux
façons premièrement nous touchons tous
les deux l'allocation chômage qui ce qui
se résume ainsi on touche 16500 24 ans
tous les 14 jours et d'autre part ma
femme touche une somme de l'assedic qui
est à le chômage complémentaires et qui
est versé par une cotisation brière et
patronales cette somme qu'elle touche se
compose à l'essence 300 360 sans 360 ce
qui nous donne environ une cinquantaine
de milles francs par mois
là-dessus naturellement il faut que vous
nous payons le gaz l'électricité le
chauffage d'éclairage et notre loyer ce
qui fait que nous sommes obligés de
vivre avec à peu près 1000 francs par
jour et heureusement que heureusement
enfin c'est une façon de s'exprimer que
nous sommes un d'un âge assez avancé
nous ne pouvons pas de cette somme là ne
permet pas de pouvoir nous habiller et
avec les moyens aussi restreint que nous
avons le les vêtements tout ça nous
évitons d'en acheter le plus possible en
ce qui nous concerne en ce qui concerne
pour moi en tant que chômeur je trouve
que l'indemnité gouvernementale est
vraiment trop faible
il est indiscutable que à l'heure
actuelle on donne environ 5 francs 80
par jour un chômeur pour pouvoir
subvenir à ses besoins
alors que l'on donne 11 francs un chien
policier pour pouvoir de nourrir je
voudrais poser un autre problème c'est
que puisque à l'heure actuelle il ya
environ quatre cent cinquante mille
chômeurs en france pourquoi ne mettons
pas la retraite à 60 ans il est
indiscutable qu'à l'heure actuelle même
dans les professions ou dans la
chaussure par exemple où il ya beaucoup
de chômage pas seulement à paris mais
dans l'ensemble de la france et en
particulier et cuirs et peaux aussi dans
l'habillement par exemple est ce qu'il
ne serait pas possible de le ramener de
d'appliquer la loi de 40 heures qui a
été prêté en 1936 interdisant les heures
supplémentaires
tant qu'il ya des ouvriers et des
ouvrières en chômage dans la corporation
alors je voudrais aussi dire que ce
n'était pas le cas tout le monde mais
moi dans mon métier j'aimais beaucoup
mon métier parce que c'était un métier
très intéressant et du fait qu'on
travaille dans des maisons qui étaient
très cotés comme la maison pire obligé à
par exemple le travail que nous faisions
était un travail qui demande un travail
perlé pour une exposition de métiers
quoi et vraiment cela me manque mais à
l'heure actuelle du fait du changement
de la transformation du métier
je ne vois pas comment je pourrais avoir
de nouveau une activité
[Musique]